.
Acht Tage, 76 km
und fast 6'000 Höhenmeter -
drei Frauen und drei Männer
erfüllen sich ihren Lebenstraum:
ein Trekking auf den Kilimandscharo -
das Dach Afrikas.
(Schluchzend)
Aber ins Spital will ich nicht.
Ursula musste abbrechen,
sie hatte Herzprobleme.
Die anderen kämpfen weiter.
Aber die dünne Luft macht immer mehr
Mühe und die Anspannung steigt.
Ich bin ziemlich nervös.
Jeder sagt:
"Wenn du an den Berg kommst,
spürst du es schon noch."
Noch drei Tage bis zum Gipfel.
Werden sie es schaffen?
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
9 Uhr morgens.
Bitte die richtige Reihenfolge
einnehmen.
(Sandra) Ich bin heute hinten.
Fabian komm,
du musst noch nach vorne.
Daniels Magen
geht es ein bisschen besser.
Bergführer Priskus hat entschieden,
spät loszulaufen,
um Stau zu vermeiden.
Es wartet die berühmte Breakfast
oder Baranco Wall.
Nach der 200 m hohen Wand geht es
dem Berg entlang rauf und runter,
rauf und runter bis
zum 6 km entfernten Karanga Camp.
Zu überwinden sind 680 Höhenmeter.
Etwa 700 Leute
haben im Camp übernachtet.
Nicht alle
haben gleich viel Erfahrung am Berg.
(Sandra) Stau.
(Damaris) Stau auf der A1
in Richtung Karanga Camp.
(Sandra) Guten Morgen,
das sind die Traffic-Nachrichten.
Wow!
Wie kommen die hier
mit dem Gepäck hoch?
You go first.
(Damaris) Hey, no problem, go.
Es geht gut.
Für uns Schweizer
ist das nicht so eine Sache.
Ich darf nicht zu fest hinsehen,
was die machen.
(Priskus) Great.
- Good, thank you.
Sie wissen, wie man jeden Schritt
hier nehmen muss, aus Erfahrung.
Und ...
Aber was die Porters hier leisten,
ist heftigste Arbeit, die schuften.
Schweizer Bergerfahrung hilft.
Die gefährlichste Stelle ist so eng,
dass man den Felsen beinahe
küssen kann, deshalb der Name.
Ist das der Kissing Rock?
- Wir küssen ihn.
(Damaris) I thought
it would be more narrow.
Küss ihn! - Ich habe es mir
schlimmer vorgestellt.
(Sandra) Hello.
- (Fabian) Thank you.
(Damaris) Seitwärts durch. Ich habe
es mir schlimmer vorgestellt.
Klaus, gib ihm einen Schmatz.
Alors, c'est cela.
- Hug the rock tightly.
* Klaus küsst den Felsen. *
And kiss it.
* Dynamische Musik *
Nach gut 2 Std.
ist der schwierigste Teil geschafft.
(Klaus) Sandra, pole pole, Sandra.
- Okay, danke.
Solche Herausforderungen
mag ich eigentlich.
Ja.
Die Pumpe geht, aber noch schön.
Ich habe geschwitzt,
weil ich zu viel angezogen habe.
Ich habe so viel angezogen,
20'000 Schichten,
weil ich ein bisschen erkältet bin
bzw. eine Sinusitis habe.
Da habe ich gedacht:
"Besser zu warm statt zu kalt."
Aber jetzt
habe ich ein bisschen übertrieben.
Ja, zuerst - aber wohl,
weil ich nicht ganz fit bin -
habe ich die Wand angeschaut
und gedacht: "Scheisse!"
Aber jetzt, wo es vorbei ist,
muss ich sagen: "Es war cool."
Das ist sicher ein Stück weit
ausserhalb der Komfortzone.
Ich probiere jetzt einfach
genau das zu machen,
was uns Kurt
mit auf den Weg gegeben hat:
auf den Körper hören.
Und wenn ich merke,
dass es etwas zu schnell ist,
gehe ich mein Tempo -
mit dem Ziel, anzukommen.
Das war einfach nur toll,
total cool.
Und jetzt diese Belohnung
mit diesem Ausblick - da fliegst du.
Fabian vermisst seinen Alltag
keine Sekunde.
Es ist,
als würde ich hierhergehören.
So eine Distanz zu all dem habe ich
noch nie in meinem Leben gehabt.
Also ...
So abschalten können von all dem,
tut mir recht gut.
(Guide) Take it easy.
- (Damaris) Ja.
* Dynamische Musik *
(Priskus) Jambo.
(Brigit) Me too, I am very proud.
(Priskus) Damaris.
Brother.
- (Fabian) Hey.- Good job.
Klaus, good job.
- Hey. - Well done, bro.
Priskus' Schwester Brigit
ist mitgekommen,
obwohl sie völlig untrainiert ist.
Sie kämpft sich jeden Tag
den Berg hoch.
Mein Vater wäre so stolz auf mich.
Nicht viele Afrikanerinnen
machen das.
Ich bin glücklich,
dass ich diese Möglichkeit habe.
Warum soll ich es nicht geniessen?
Ich geniesse es sehr.
(Sandra) Jump, jump, jump, jump.
* Jubel *
* Dynamische Musik *
Das sieht wahnsinnig aus.
(Alle) Eins, zwei, drei!
Weiter in der alpinen Wüste.
Rauf und runter.
Es zieht sich.
Wenn ich merke,
dass ich an die Grenze komme,
höre ich meine Musik
und kann den Kopf ausschalten.
Ich überlege nicht, ob ich
noch kann, sondern laufe nur noch.
Alle gehen unterschiedlich um
mit den Herausforderungen am Berg.
Wenn ich nicht raufkomme,
wird es mir keine Ruhe geben.
Du weisst,
du bist weit ab vom Schuss.
Du kannst nicht einfach sagen:
"Ich breche jetzt ab, fertig."
Ich finde es schwierig,
wenn ich so lange unterwegs bin,
dass man weiterläuft und das Ziel
nicht aus den Augen verliert,
die Motivation, zu sagen:
"Ich gehe weiter, ich gehe weiter."
Nach knapp 5 Std.:
das Karanga Camp auf 3'995 m Höhe.
(Sandra) Geschafft!
(Fabian) Es ist nicht mehr weit.
Der letzte Aufstieg war schon steil,
der hatte es in sich,
aber auf den hat er uns
zum Glück vorbereitet,
sodass wir noch Energie hatten
für diesen letzten Aufstieg.
(Priskus) Let's go.
Everybody say: "Kili!"
(Alle) Kili!
- Kilimanjaro!- (Alle) Kilimanjaro!
Lovely.
Kaum angekommen, hat Klaus als Arzt
wieder alle Hände voll zu tun.
Daniel geht es wieder gut, doch nun
kämpfen die Träger mit Durchfall.
Ich bin überrascht von Klaus.
Der nimmt sich da echt Zeit
und Musse.
Er will voll bereit sein
für den Kili.
Wenn man sich so angestrengt hat
und dann Toilette machen kann,
ist das einfach ein Wohlgefühl.
Ein bisschen Wohlfühloase.
* Rhythmische Musik *
Die Gruppe ist zusammengewachsen
in den letzten Tagen.
Der Umgang sehr vertraut - so, als
würden sie sich schon lange kennen.
Dann hören wir wieder besser.
- Holy shit, hey!
Danke dir.
- Bitte, bitte.
Auch die Frauen
sind best friends geworden.
Es ist halt staubig.
Wir realisierten das gestern
auch als Gruppe:
Sandra war unsere Icebreakerin,
schon am Flughafen.
Das hat uns so gut getan,
in kürzester Zeit die Hüllen
voreinander fallen zu lassen
und wirklich nach kurzer Zeit
schon persönliche und
intime Gespräche führen zu dürfen,
die sonst im Leben
nicht so schnell entstehen würden.
Ich meine,
wir sind zehn, zwölf Tage zusammen.
Da finde ich es wichtig, dass man
eine gute Basis miteinander hat,
denn hier oben können wir uns
nicht aus dem Weg gehen.
Darum ist es so wichtig, dass man
die anderen auch akzeptiert,
wie sie sind,
mit ihren Ecken und Kanten.
Und egal, ob das einem passt
oder nicht, es ist so.
Man muss hier oben
das Beste daraus machen.
Das macht man,
indem man ein Team wird -
oder wie wir untereinander sagen:
"Wir sind die Kili-Familie."
Finally.
Auch Brigit hat es geschafft.
Der Gipfeltag kommt näher,
das beschäftigt alle.
Also, starten wir.
Wichtig: Je weiter du hochkommst,
umso dünner wird die Luft
und umso schwieriger ist das Atmen.
Dementsprechend
ist es umso wichtiger,
dass du ganz tief
in den Bauch atmest
und die Luft vom Bauch
auch wieder rauslässt.
Dafür gibt es schöne Bauchübungen.
Halte die Hände auf den Bauch.
- Bauchatmung?- Genau.
Jetzt machst du die Augen zu,
entspannst dich und beginnst,
ganz tief hinunterzuatmen.
Ich werde Musik hören,
Kopf nach unten,
und wenn ich an meine Grenzen komme,
werde ich so atmen.
Ja, das werde ich ausprobieren.
- Ja, mach das. Das machen wir.
So, jetzt gehe ich
Handyempfang suchen.
So, und ich gehe mich ausruhen.
Du gehst ausruhen.
Sleep well, little tiger.
A dopo. Zuerst wieder anziehen.
Die Einheimischen
haben noch ein Abendprogramm:
Simba SC und Young Africans SC -
die beiden erfolgreichsten Clubs
Tansanias - spielen gegeneinander.
* Suaheli *
* Ruhige Musik *
Thank you.
Alle haben gut geschlafen,
auch Sandra ist wieder fit.
Sie hat ihre Sinusitis auch ohne
Antibiotika unter Kontrolle gebracht.
Doch immer mehr Träger
haben gesundheitliche Probleme.
Judith ist die einzige Frau
in der Crew und das erste Mal dabei.
Sie hat drei Kinder und eine Mutter,
die sie durchbringen muss.
Seit gestern
hat sie starke Kopfschmerzen,
und die werden immer schlimmer.
Sie hat den Appetit verloren,
fühlt sich sehr schwach.
Ich habe entschieden, dass sie
ins untere Camp absteigen soll.
Dann wird es ihr besser gehen.
Ihren Lohn bekommt sie trotzdem?
- Ja, ja, sie bekommt alles.
Das könnte ja auch mir passieren.
Auch wenn sie schon am ersten Tag
runtergegangen wäre,
würde sie das ganze Geld bekommen,
so funktioniert das hier.
Warum macht sie als einzige Frau
hier den harten Job überhaupt?
* Suaheli *
* Sie antwortet auf Suaheli. *
Sie sagt, sie brauche das Geld
für ihre Familie.
Sie muss den Job machen.
Es ist eine Herausforderung
mit all den Männern,
aber sie hat keine Wahl.
Damas, Priskus' Onkel,
hat eine Bindehautentzündung.
(Klaus) Ich sorge mich
um seine Cornea. - (Damaris) Mhm.
Thank you so much.
Jetzt sind beide Augen betroffen.
Sie haben geeitert
und jetzt haben wir sie ausgewaschen
und antibiotische Tropfen reingetan
und hoffen, es geht ihm besser.
Der Jüngste in der Crew
ist Priskus' Schwager Hussein.
Auch er ist das erste Mal am Berg.
Er schaut jung aus, aber er ist 20.
Wenn du unter 18 bist,
darfst du im Park
nicht als Träger arbeiten.
Tourismus ist mein Traum.
Ich will Tourismus studieren.
Ich bin nicht nur
wegen des Geldes mitgekommen,
ich will auch Erfahrungen sammeln
im Tourismus.
Geld ist schon auch wichtig,
aber ich will v.a.
mehr über diesen Berg wissen.
Okay.
Weil es im obersten Camp
kein Wasser gibt,
müssen die Träger umpacken.
220 l Wasser
haben wir schon raufgetragen,
aber wir benötigen nochmals 120 l.
Um die raufzutragen, brauchen wir
allein sechs, sieben Leute,
darum müssen wir den Rest umpacken.
* Suaheli *
(Sandra) Klaus, bist du ready?
(Klaus) Sandra.
- Ja, ich gehe hinten.
Klaus' Lieblingsspruch:
"Sandra, retour!"
Ich bin das Schlusslicht.
Heute geht es knapp 5 km durch die
alpine Steinwüste zum Barafu Camp -
dem letzten
vor dem grossen Gipfeltag.
Zu überwinden sind 630 Höhenmeter.
Das Tempo wird langsamer,
die Nervosität steigt.
Jetzt bist du beruhigt, chillig.
Ich mache das Schlusslicht.
- Gut.
* Ruhige Musik *
Hussein hat sich
an die Anstrengung gewöhnt.
Am ersten Tag noch
ist er fast zusammengebrochen.
Das Hauptproblem
waren die vielen Kilometer.
Und ich hatte Kopfschmerzen.
Ich habe die Lasten abgelegt
und bin eingeschlafen, 30 Min.
Es war so hart für mich.
Ich habe Gott gedankt, dass ich
überhaupt im Camp angekommen bin.
* Ruhige Musik *
(Sandra) Wie schnell
sind wir im Schnitt gewesen?
(Daniel) 2 km/h.
- (Überrascht) Was?
(Klaus) Das ist gut.
- Wow!
Er schlägt
ein schön langsames Tempo an.
Das ist angenehm
und eine gute Vorbereitung.
Bestens. Geht tipptopp.
- Ja, sehr gut. Daumen hoch.
Das ist voll geil.
Habt ihr den Puls gemessen?
- Er hat ihn gemessen.
Jetzt sind wir bei 110.
Und mit 2 km/h sind wir am Laufen.
- Ja, schön gemütlich.
Zu langsam? - Nein, ich spare
Energie für den Abend.- Richtig.
Ich laufe zuhinterst,
damit ich Energie sparen kann.
Ich habe mir das vorgenommen,
damit ich heute Abend ...
Also nicht zu schnell,
aber so, dass ich raufkomme.
Körner sparen.
- Ja.
Wir Velofahrer
laufen halt gerne im Windschatten.
Jetzt gibt es nur noch ein Ziel:
Wir brauchen jedes Korn bis rauf.
Ja.
Nachher können wir leer sein.
Tank empty.
Nein, wir müssen noch 3'000 m
runter.- Da rollen wir.
* Ruhige Musik *
Nur noch wenige Hundert Meter
bis zum Camp.
* Ruhige Musik *
(Sandra) Alles klar?
(Klaus) Ja, ich muss nur mein Tempo
gehen, dann ist gut.- Gut.
Wenn ich das kann ...
Sorry, bin nicht mehr so gesprächig.
- Ich weiss.
Alles gut,
ich weiss, dass du leidest.
Darum will ich dich motivieren.
Sag, wenn du das nicht willst.
Nein, ich schätze das sehr,
auch wenn ich nicht reagiere.
Schau, da ist es schon.
So wie du zu mir gekommen bist
und gesagt hast,
du brauchst mich ein bisschen ...
Ich brauche dich genau gleich.
- Gut.
All the way around.
- Das packen wir.
Dafür sind Freunde da.
Dort oben hast du es geschafft,
du packst das.
Tief atmen nicht vergessen, gell.
Richtig in den Bauch runter
und rauf atmen, das ist das A und O.
In den Bauch atmen.
Schau, man sieht es schon!
(Fabian) Da sind wir.
- Thank you, Simon, good job.
(Simon) Congratulations.
- Thanks.
Picture after picture.
Gratuliere.
- Gleichfalls.
Jetzt stehen dort
nur noch zwei Zahlen.
Stimmt,
aber die machen wir am Stück.
Ja.
Wir sind da für dich.
Die Motivationskugel ist da.
Oh, jetzt falle ich gleich um.
- Ja, mit zwei Frauen.
Thank you.
Von der Felswand hier rauf
habe ich gemerkt,
jetzt muss ich mein Tempo gehen,
sonst kommt es nicht gut.
Sandra hat gemerkt, dass ich
ruhiger geworden bin vor ihr,
nicht mehr so viel gequasselt habe.
Aber ich glaube,
wenn man merkt, dass man
einen Gang runterschalten muss,
dann muss man das machen
in den Bergen.
Ich bin schon 12 Std. voraus.
Ich warte auf das, was kommt.
Totale Vorfreude, dort hochzugehen.
Ich möchte am liebsten
jetzt loslaufen.
Ich weiss, es geht nicht,
alles okay,
aber jetzt ist es so nahe,
wir sind noch nie so nahe gewesen.
* Fröhlicher Gesang *
Es ist der 15. August.
Eine indische Gruppe
feiert den Unabhängigkeitstag.
* Ruhige Musik *
(Klaus)
Hey, ich bin direkt neben euch.
Trocken ist es hier.
Das knappe Wasser muss reichen
fürs Händewaschen und zum Kochen.
(Klaus) Oh!
- (Fabian) Nice, thank you.
(Damaris) Asante sana.
- (Klaus) Oh, wow!
Oh, Fleisch - das ist mein Teller.
(Koch) It's chicken.
- (Alle) Chicken.
Wer isst schon auf 4'673 m Pommes?
Ich finde, das ist
eine five star deluxe kitchen hier.
Die kochen geiler als ich für mich.
Ich kann nicht kochen.
Es gibt Salat und Fleisch.
Priskus gibt letzte Tipps
für den Gipfeltag.
Mitten in der Nacht
wird es losgehen -
im Zickzack hinauf
bis zum Stella Point am Kraterrand.
Von dort sind es noch 100 Höhenmeter
bis zum Gipfel.
Es wäre eine Schande,
wenn ihr Stella Point erreicht
und dort nicht weitermacht,
bloss, weil ihr müde seid.
Das ist normal. Oder weil ihr euch
schwach oder schläfrig fühlt.
Von dort aus
ist es wirklich ein Kinderspiel.
Sawa sawa?
- (Alle) Sawa sawa.
Nur die sieben Guides
gehen mit auf den Gipfel.
Wer kann, versucht,
etwas vorzuschlafen -
nicht ganz einfach.
(Damaris) Ich bin verunsichert,
weil ich keine Vorzeichen hatte,
aber jeder sagt:
"Wenn du an den Berg kommst,
spürst du es dann schon noch."
Wie fühlt sich denn das an?
Kommt alles auf einmal?
(Sandra) Wenn alles auf einmal
kommt, dann viel Spass.
* Sanfte Musik *
Die ersten Gruppen
gehen schon um Mitternacht los.
Um Stau beim Aufstieg zu vermeiden,
hat Priskus entschieden,
seine Gruppe erst um 2 Uhr zu wecken.
Lustigerweise hat niemand
daran gedacht, mich zu wecken.
Ich habe dann die anderen gehört,
als sie aufgestanden sind,
sonst wäre ich noch am Schlafen.
Alle haben sich so warm wie möglich
angezogen.
Es ist -14 °C.
(Sandra) Hui, es ist heiss.
Wovor haben sie am meisten Respekt?
Also bei mir sind es zwei Sachen:
die Höhe und die Kälte.
Wie kalt wird es?
Jetzt finde ich es ...
Ich bin gut angezogen, friere nicht,
und mit dem Laufen wird es wärmer,
aber was passiert
mit jedem Schritt nach oben?
Wie streng wird es gegen Ende,
wenn die Luft richtig dünn wird?
(Sandra) Ich mache mir mehr Sorgen
wegen des Atmens.
Dass die Symptome der Höhenkrankheit
kommen oder was auch immer.
Es bereitet mir Sorgen,
dass man fast oben umkehren muss,
wegen der Atmung, oder dass einem
plötzlich schwindlig wird.
Davor habe ich mehr Respekt,
fast schon Angst.
Ich nehme es Schritt für Schritt -
im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes.
Die letzte Etappe führt 5 Std.
steil hinauf bis zum Stella Point
am Kraterrand und von dort
noch 1 Std. und 100 Höhenmeter weiter
bis zum Uhuru Peak,
dem höchsten Punkt Afrikas.
* Priskus instruiert auf Suaheli. *
Priskus ist streng katholisch:
keine Gipfelbesteigung ohne Gebet.
* Priskus betet auf Suaheli. *
(Priskus) Amen.
- (Alle) Amen.
* Klatschen, Anfeuerungsrufe *
* Jemand ruft mehrmals laut
nach Augustin. *
(Daniel)
Dass die immer so hupen müssen.
(Damaris) Wegen dieses Geschreis
war es heute Nacht so laut.
Kann man das nicht unten besprechen?
* Damaris lacht. *
* Rufe auf Suaheli *
Das hat mit der Mentalität zu tun.
Sie sagen doch:
"Es gibt kein Problem vorher."
Sie lösen die Probleme erst,
wenn sie da sind.
Knapp 1'300 Höhenmeter
liegen vor ihnen.
* Rhythmische Musik *
Wegen der Kälte wird es
nur ein paar kurze Trinkpausen geben.
* Rhythmische Musik *
(Damaris) Okay.
- (Priskus) We are nearly there.
Wie läuft es?
(Daniel) Es läuft.
- (Damaris) Es läuft.
Jetzt habe ich
fest Hunger bekommen.
Mir ist schon fast - oh, ups -
schlecht.
Kopfweh ist gut,
ich habe nichts genommen.
Ich habe gedacht:
"Abwarten, ob es besser wird."
Ja, es ist besser geworden.
* Rhythmische Musik *
Wir haben die nächste
magische Grenze überschritten:
Wir sind bei 5'002 Höhenmetern.
(Damaris) Juhu!
- (Klaus) Uff!
(Priskus) Hakuna matata!
(Priskus) Okay, okay.
Sawa sawa.
- Willkommen auf 5'000 m.
Geil.
* Die Guides singen auf Suaheli. *
(Priskus) Okay, guys.
* Die Guides singen und klatschen. *
(Daniel) Die kennen nichts.
- (Damaris) Dass die noch singen.
(Damaris) Meine Güte.
Einige laufen.
"Sibesieche"!
Die kann man nicht anders nennen.
Das ist Motivation für uns.
(Alle) Hakuna matata!
(Guide) Lovely, lovely.
Ich habe etwas taube Füsse.
Ähm ... Ich habe sehr fest Hunger
und ein bisschen Kopfweh.
Es ist kalt.
Ich laufe wie in einem Tunnel.
Dann geht es, aber ...
... die Welt rundherum
blende ich komplett aus
und ich laufe, ohne zu überlegen.
Im Moment einfach
von Pause zu Pause.
Aber ja, man atmet einfach
die ganze Zeit mit jedem Schritt.
Ja.
* Rhythmische Musik *
(Damaris) Oh, schau!
(Daniel) Gewaltig.
(Damaris) Oh, wow!
Es wird dort drüben immer schöner.
(Daniel) Das ist gewaltig.
Ich habe das Gefühl, man könne fast
die Rundung der Erde erahnen.- Ja.
(Klaus) Ja, und wie.
- (Damaris) Mega.
(Daniel) Es ist gigantisch.
(Damaris) Ein mega Farbenspektakel.
- (Klaus) Ja.
* Rhythmische Musik *
(Daniel)
Schau, jetzt wird der Fels rot.
(Damaris) Ja, es taucht den
ganzen Kilimandscharo ins Morgenrot.
Der Gletscher ist das i-Tüpfelchen
in der ganzen Szenerie.
Genau deswegen bin ich hier.
So könnte es ewig weitergehen.
Sprachlos.
Es ist mega, ja.
Es ist besser ...
... als jede Vorstellung.
Ich weiss jetzt, warum die Leute
immer wieder hier hochkommen.
Es ist wahnsinnig.
So habe ich es mir
nicht vorgestellt.
Es ist gigantisch.
* Sanfte Musik *
Wir gehen weiter.
(Priskus) Gut gemacht, Leute.
Good job! Welcome!
Wir machen 5 Min. Pause.
Bis jetzt läuft alles gut.
Alle glücklich - und nicht mehr weit
bis zum Stella Point.
Alle glücklich und noch am Leben.
Das ist sehr wichtig für mich.
* Ein Guide singt fröhlich. *
(Sandra) Wieso kann der
noch so herumspringen? Cooler Typ.
(Kurt) Sandra, möchtest du noch?
- (Sandra) Nein, ist gut, danke.
Ich habe dieselbe Musik
rund 20-mal gehört -
Zeit für eine andere.
Die stelle ich jetzt ein -
und sonst eigentlich gut.
Wenn hier die Sonne aufgeht,
sieht es aus wie in einem Traum.
Man ist gespannt:
"Wie weit geht es noch,
wie lange müssen
bzw. dürfen wir noch?"
Es ist aber wirklich megacool.
Ah, meine Hände.
Nicht normal, nein.
Sieh dir das an!
Ich bin sprachlos.
- (Damaris) Gell?
Diese Vorstellung:
Wir sind zuoberst
auf diesem Riesenkontinent.
Es ist so schön.
(Daniel) Weisst du,
wie wir raufgehen? Zehnmal noch.
Das könnte ewig so weitergehen.
- Yes, I come.
Ewig könnte das so weitergehen.
* Damaris keucht. *
Aber nach diesem Moment
trägt mich mein Herz hier hoch.
* Sanfte Musik *
Noch etwa 2 Std.
sind es bis zum Stella Point.
* Sanfte Musik *
(Damaris) Oh, ist es dort oben?
Stella Point ist in Sichtweite,
aber noch eine Stunde entfernt.
(Damaris) So, die nehmen wir noch.
(Sandra) Wo machen wir Pause?
Dort oben?
(Damaris) Siehst du das Ziel?
Komm, Klausi, Break.
- Pause.
(Daniel) Klausi, Mausi.
Ich bin so froh,
spüre ich nicht mehr.
Es ist ein Riesengeschenk.
Ich habe wirklich damit gerechnet,
dass uns schwindlig wird,
Kopfschmerzen ...
Ich habe mit dem Schlimmsten
gerechnet.
Ja. Und ...
So schön, den Berg besteigen
zu dürfen und es geht gut.
Ich höre Musik und versuche,
den Soundtext zu übersetzen.
Dann schaue ich auf und denke:
"Wie weit ist es noch?"
Dann denke ich: "Stell dich
nicht so an und lauf weiter!"
Dann geht es.
Mit der Luft geht es super.
Ich merke zum Glück
keinen Unterschied.
Aber es kann ja immer noch kommen.
Wir haben noch rund 250 Höhenmeter.
Da kann sich noch viel ändern.
Ich bin schon am Kämpfen.
Mit den Beinen geht es.
Ich schleppe mich einfach hier hoch,
aber ...
... Kopfschmerzen
habe ich schon sehr.
Aber da beisse ich mich jetzt durch.
Jetzt spielt es keine Rolle mehr.
Ich möchte gerade
ewig so weitlaufen.
Ich bin komplett
in diesem Runner's High drin,
das ich von früher kenne.
Der Diesel wurde im Endorphin-Flow
so richtig angeworfen.
Es läuft einfach nur noch.
Ich schleiche, das ist richtig.
Ich habe einfach gemerkt,
wenn ich genau diese Pace mache,
die mir mein Körper erlaubt,
dann kommt es gut.
Ihr schafft das, ihr alle.
Okay, guys.
* Dynamische Musik *
Nur noch ein paar Hundert Meter
bis zum Stella Point,
aber die sind die schlimmsten.
* Dynamische Musik *
(Daniel) Uh, Stella!
Schau mal den Gletscher dort hinten!
(Damaris) Wow!
Yes!
Yeah!
- Geschafft!
* Damaris seufzt erleichtert. *
Die erste Hürde haben wir.
Uhuru is just over there.
- Yeah, nothing.
A piece of cake.
Hey, Jesse!
- Give me a hug.- Thank you.
* Pfiffe *
* Jubel *
Kili, kili, kili!
Und noch eine Stunde
bis zum Uhuru Peak.
* Sanfte Musik *
(Guide) Kilimanjaro - Hakuna ...
- (Damaris) ... Matata!
* Mystische Klänge *
Damaris, this is the roof of Africa.
Finally, you: Kili, Kili.
- (Sandra) Kili, Kili.
Congratulations, good job.
- (Damaris) Thank you.
(Priskus) Well done, well done.
(Sandra) Schätzchen!
(Priskus) Congratulations, bro.
- (Fabian) Thank you, Priskus.
Du hast es geschafft, deinen Traum!
Du bist ein Rockstar.
- Fucking Rockstars sind wir alle.
(Priskus) Congratulations.
Good job, bro, well done.
Klaus, finally!
Roof of Africa!
Congratulations, Klaus.
Congratulations.
Good job, well done.
- Thank you, Augustin.
Not bad.- The highest freestandig
in the world.- Thank you, man.
Hey, super Leistung, gut gemacht.
Du bist tot, wir schaffen das.
Ich bin tot.
- Hallo, ich bin hier.
Warte schnell!
* Kuss *
(Damaris) Wir haben es geschafft.
* Damaris atmet tief aus. *
(Klaus) Zusammen.
Keine Wolke, keine einzige Wolke.
Es ist definitiv
ausserhalb der Komfortzone,
aber jeder Schritt hat sich gelohnt.
Es ist unglaublich.
So schön.
Ich kann jeden verstehen,
der diesem Virus verfällt, und sagt:
"Ich komme wieder."
Oder: "Ich gehe auf weitere Berge."
So über den Wolken:
Freiheit.
Hey, buddy.
Geil gemacht.
Wahnsinn!
Es hat mir alles zugeschnürt.
Ich habe kein Wort rausgebracht.
Ich kann mit Sicherheit sagen:
Das ist die Nummer 1
der schönsten Dinge,
die ich je unternommen habe.
* Erhabene Musik *
(Alle) # Jambo, jambo bwana!
# Habari gani?
# Mzuri sana.
# Wageni wakaribishwa.
# Kilimanjaro - Hakuna matata!
* Jubel *
(Guide) Oh, là, là, mamma mia!
* Erhabene Musik *
(Damaris) Ich nehme viele Bilder
vom Kilimandscharo mit.
Ich nehme Freunde mit.
(Guide und Damaris) Bye-bye, Kili.
Und die Erkenntnis, dass man immer
an seinen Träumen festhalten soll.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
puretype gmbh - 2023